[Musica]
la sera per i presenti era il 1968
quando usciva nelle sale
cinematografiche di tutto il mondo
un film di fantascienza che è rimasto
nella storia 2001 odissea nello spazio
questo film tra i primi raccontava in
modo intelligente la relazione tra
l'uomo e la macchina
ricorderete c'era un computer super
computer al 12 mila che aveva il
controllo della missione e della
negazione della nave del dell'astronave
c'era un comandante che è il
protagonista del film comandate bosman
che chiaramente operava aveva il comando
della missione fino al raggiungimento di
giove a questo computer aveva
responsabilità della missione
addirittura aveva delle consegne
speciali da parte del comando centrale
per cui nemmeno il comandante bosman
sapeva qual era la vera missione che
doveva compiere d'astronave questo film
non abbiano i cinque anni quando mio
padre mi portò al cinema mi colpì molto
il fatto che un computer una macchina
potesse avere il comando di una missione
che conoscesse tutte le cose di cui ha
bisogno per prendere le decisioni e di
fatto
aveva il comando e ricordo anche la
paura che mi restava da bambino il fatto
che una macchina potesse avere il
comando
temevo che questa cosa potesse andare a
firmare questa voce così metallica è un
po fredda no ricorderete nel film è poi
così andò ci fu un conflitto e alla fine
uomo in macchina si scontrarono il
computer voleva eliminare il comandante
bowman poi alla fine lui ebbe il
sopravvento e ricorderete il film bene
ma questo sta diventando oggi una realtà
cioè uomini e macchine che collaborano
vivono insieme collaborano per
realizzare cose sempre più complesse per
gestire sistemi sempre più complessi
immaginate per esempio un sistema così
complesso ma può essere la fabbrica del
futuro per la produzione industriale di
qualsiasi bene come fatto mobili per
esempio o un sistema complesso non può
essere quello di un porto marittimo
industriale che deve organizzare le sue
le sue operazioni
ebbene ci viene in mente che oggi
abbiamo le tecnologie di calcolo della
tassa in computer science che permette
di avere laboratori sempre più potenti
le tecnologie del cloud computing che
consentono di potenziale di molto la
capacità elaborative e le tecniche
intelligenze artificiali appunto che
consentono alla alla macchina anche di
imparare e di poter prendere delle
decisioni
ma c'è un'altra tecnologia che è
fondamentale anche tutto ciò si realizzi
pensiamo a un altro sistema complesso
che è quello del nostro organismo umano
c'è un cervello che capisce a delle
sensazioni prende delle decisioni e
muove cioè facile tutti i muscoli del
corpo fa camminare fa correre fa giocare
fa fare tutto quello che possiamo fare
bene questo cervello può far tutto ciò
solo perché ci sono una miriade di
sensori biologici che danno l'esatta
comunicazione di quello
che il loro stato quello che gli occhi
vedono le orecchie sentono eccetera e
quindi il cervello prende le sue
decisioni quindi che abbiamo che la
comunicazione è l'alta tecnologia che
costituisce un po la vede angolare
insieme a quella del computer a computer
santi la con la comunicazione tra
oggetti e le macchine e le entità
intelligenti e le persone
questo è diciamo un po il punto centrale
è del mio intervento
oggi si sente parlare di industria 4.0
beh questo non è altro che il da avere
la possibilità di digitalizzare ogni
sistema complesso fatto di cose
materiali e anche non materiale come
ripeto appunto una fabbrica
digitalizzarla significa tradurre questo
sistema fisico molto hardware in un
sistema informativo per cui è
l'intelligenza umana e tutta la capacità
computazionale è in grado poi alla fine
di darne una rappresentazione
semplificata affinché la persona o la
macchina o entrambe possano prendere le
decisioni giuste affinché si evitino
conseguenze spiacevoli si evitano
incidenti si ottimizzano le prestazioni
del sistema complesso per aumentare la
produttività per aumentare il livello di
servizio al cittadino se pensiamo a
l'utilizzo di sistemi complessi di
questo tipo nel mondo ospedaliero della
sanità ad esempio il pallino di
comunicazione e noi siamo abituati se
avessi parlato di comunicazione 20 anni
fa era soprattutto la telefonia
cominciava e la telefonia mobile
abbiamo questa slide e è interessante
vedere come ci sono voluti 100 anni per
portare per connettere un miliardo di
posti fisici case abitazioni uffici e
quant'altro
in 25 anni abbiamo avuto 5 miliardi di
persone connesse attraverso un terminale
mobile
come o meno un telefonino o una internet
key e nei prossimi 4 5 anni avremo
qualche cosa tipo 30 miliardi di oggetti
connessi
quindi la frontiera delle
telecomunicazioni è quella di connettere
gli oggetti connettere le cose il 5 g
non è una tecnologia che ci consentirà
di avere ancora più capacità a
disposizione o non è solo una tecnologia
per avere capacità e prestazioni delle
reti per avere un'esperienza broadband
mobile per tutti noi per state già negli
ultimi 15 anni quanto sia profondamente
cambiata la nostra vita grazie allo
smartphone ai servizi la messaggeria e
social network e quant'altro pensate
quanto possa cambiare la nostra vita
quando avverrà che gli oggetti connessi
faranno sì che si possano ottenere
servizi i più disparati e produzioni e
in qualche modo sempre più competitive
5gb dire comunicazione tra oggetti
ovviamente ci sono vari tipi di oggetti
o qui non voglio
come dire fare una persona mia del tipo
di comunicazione ma solo riflettere su
un fatto se ad esempio sto monitorando
un una vigna
no sono ritornando temperatura umidità
di un terreno delle piante di questa
venia probabilmente ho bisogno di
pochissimi dati anche milano la
possibilità di capire come stanno
andando le cose e magari avere un
sistema esperto che dice al contadino
guarda considerato tutto è meglio che il
raccolto lo facciamo la prossima
settimana ma se io e questo è un tipo di
comunicazione tra oggetti cioè sensori
sul terreno o in aria che comunicano con
un'entità un sistema esperto che è in
grado di gestire enormi quantità di dati
si chiama big data
e poi c'è una in qualche modo un sistema
in grado di fornire un'interpretazione
di questi dati e magari con dei
suggerimenti di azione anticipa dai ti
amo dei pesticidi perché il sistema si è
accorto che ci sono le condizioni per
cui un parassita potrebbe danneggiare
raccolta e quant'altro ma immaginiamo un
altro tipo di comunicazione io sto
controllando un robot che sta ad esempio
disinnescando una bomba bene
l'artificiere che in questo caso non è
vicino alla bomba ma sta controllando il
robot con un tour con un joystick o
qualcosa del genere deve avere una
sensibilità tattile come se lui stesse
toccando con le proprie dita
l'oggetto per i tagliare i fili giusti o
se sto se un chirurgo sta facendo
un'operazione da remoto
in questo caso ho bisogno di una
capacità di reazione della rete cioè dei
responsi vita delle leve tale per cui in
grado di fornirmi questa capacità questa
percezione tattile vuol dire che la rete
deve essere in grado di far sì che non
solo il segnale va da sé thorne in un
tempo breve questo ovviamente dato dalla
velocità di propagazione del segnale
elettromagnetico ma soprattutto che il
processamento del segnale nelle latency
ha fatto in maniera tale che abbia una
responsabilità e una responsabilità
dell'ordine del mille secondo di
pochissimi delle seconde
quindi questo per dire che ci sono varie
tipologie di oggetti vari requisiti no e
quindi una complessità di poter gestire
tutto questo mondo in modo tale da
soddisfare le caratteristiche che
servono
qui se possiamo vedere settore per
settore
come cambierà come già sta cambiando se
pensiamo al settore dell'automotive
vediamo che già oggi abbiamo dei servizi
per cui sono stato già citate le
informazioni noi tramite il navigatore
possiamo già oggi sapere che nel
percorso che dobbiamo fare c'è una coda
dobbiamo saltare questa governa
ci dice dove andare magari la macchina
ci dice guarda c'è un problema nel
motore forse dovresti andare dal
dall'officina entro dieci giorni perché
c'è questo tipo di problema e
quant'altro ma siamo già sulla strada
per cui abbiamo un'informazione realtà
in veicolo pubblico veicolo a veicolo
questo per esempio per poter dare
suggerimenti in tempo reale al guidatore
tipo attenzione c'è stato un incidente
trenta secondi fa rallenta perché dentro
il tunnel c'è il pericolo questo pensate
a quanto possa essere utile per
eliminare incidenti stradali importanti
una cosa di questo tipo
il futuro e le macchine a controllo
autonomo
questo non vuol dire necessariamente e
la visione ultima cioè che salire su
un'automobile
devo andare lì e l'automobile pc può sta
facendo la strada che vuole io leggo il
giornale mentre gli argini automobile ma
proprio per dire anche una coadiuva una
macchina che è in grado di aiutare il
guidatore è nelle condizioni difficili e
magari nelle condizioni noiose tipo la
coda la coda in autostrada o fantasma
abbiamo il mondo delle mense mobileblog
perché già nei prossimi vedete nel
prossimo prossimo anno nel caso
dell'impegno di seul in piedi invernali
nel 2020 in quelle di tokyo del mobile
experience importante nei giochi
olimpici per quello sputo spettatore
potrà avere una miriade di informazioni
in tempo reale sulla corsa che sta
avvenendo sulla gara che sta avvenendo
sulle informazioni sul giocatore e
quant'altro se pensiamo al mondo della
sanità già oggi abbiamo oggetti connessi
dispositivi connessi la possibilità per
esempio di di fare delle analisi da casa
o per pazienti che non si possono
muovere di avere la possibilità di fare
delle delle analisi e di trasmettere
risultato in tempo reale
siamo verso avanti la strada di andare
verso un monitoraggio e verso una
automatizzazione di certe di certe
funzionalità
in maniera tale da da da impedire le
code è pronto al pronto soccorso di
eliminare tempi morti e c'era nel futuro
ci può essere quello per esempio della
della chirurgia da remoto della della
chirurgia assistita da remoto che è un
concetto un po diverso infine sul money
faccio l'in quello che io credo verrà
prima che perché ci sono degli
investimenti importanti nel mucchio
analisti concorrono che il mondo
dell'internet delle cose vedrà nel nello
smart manifacturing gli investimenti più
importanti che proprio nei prossimi anni
l'idea di andare verso una fabbrica
intelligente la fabbrica cioè dove ogni
elemento della fabbrica e monitorato e
per esempio un sistema esperto potrebbe
accorgersi che quella vibrazione che ho
nel nastro trasportatore di quel
componente che poi arriverà il robot che
prenderei componente loro sembrera per
montare il motore nella stazione
chiesina del dell'impianto quella
vibrazione fa sì che componente a ruota
un pochino e se la rotazione esce da
certe tolleranza i robot non è più in
grado di prenderlo e quindi si si ferma
all impianto prima che questo accade
il sistema può dare la soluzione
probabilmente di un intervento che ha un
tempo molto più limitato di quello di
aspettare che poi il guaio all
l'inconveniente venga fuori e blocchi
poi la catena della distribuzione un
impianto di produzione industriale una
cosa molto complessa e potremmo avere
sistemi esperti in grado di aiutare poi
le persone che stanno lì e tre per
prendere decisioni operative a prendere
la decisione giusta comunicazione
sistemi esperti capacità computazionali
intelligenza artificiale e magari avere
una macchina super computer e che sia in
grado di agire in tempo reale per
eliminare il problema prevenirlo sono i
concetti del preventing maintenance del
predicted maintenance del dell'industria
4.0
questo è una cosa effettivamente che
avrà un impatto molto importante nella
vita nell'industria il lavoro quindi
sarà sempre di più
un lavoro collaborativo tra persone e
robot dove la parola robot la uso in
modo la radio può essere un oggetto
fisico una macchina un umanoide come
vedete lì in quel caso andiamo a nadia
di un centro di ricerca che serve per
l'assistenza agli anziani
in questo caso che deve un bambino che
sta facendo no sono decisi facendo delle
analisi per misurare della
caratteristica fisiologica e poter
capire insomma in largo anticipo se c'è
bisogno di un intervento o di altro
concludiamo tornando al film
da qui sono partito al 2009 sia nello
spazio vedete quella e l'occhio di anno
e meno sapete al è l'acronimo di
euristico e algoritmi che non avverrà
per mettere insieme i due metodi
abbastanza diversi quello
dell'intuizione del modo di procedere
nel ragionamento non programmato per
apprendimento per correzioni terrore
l'algoritmo invece quello che lo molto
più sistematico procedere secondo delle
regole molto ben molto ben molto precise
curioso che 50 anni fa un film di
fantascienza già parla di un computer di
questo tipo
ecco il tema conclude concludere questo
la comunicazione è fondamentale per dare
un quadro aggiornatissimo a chi deve
prendere decisioni uomo macchina insieme
uomo macchina
la macchina 6.000 assente se non altro
per trasformare il quadro completo di un
sistema permette complesso in maniera
tale che la persona che sta lì al
controllo sappia cosa deve fare un tempo
ragionevolmente breve un punto
interrogativo che punto di domanda che
c'è fino a che punto si può lasciare
autonomia o una macchina per poter
decidere fino a che punto si può
delegare
sicuramente interessante e penso che sia
uno dei temi dell'intelligenza
artificiale ma di certo una
comunicazione aggiornata è fondamentale
immaginate se il vostro se il vostro
cervello avesse delle informazioni di
ritardo sui sensori che sono nel vostro
corpo sarebbe sarebbe un disastro per
cui la comunicazione e l'intelligenza
artificiale saranno sempre più un'unica
cosa per poter realizzare quello che è
il futuro che è già presente
grazie per l'attenzione
[Applauso]
[Musica]